1969 le premier homme marche sur la lune
une date gravée dans l'histoire
aujourd'hui encore la conquête spatiale
susciterait et émotion dans sa première
exposition de la saison l'atelier du
science explorer le cosmos nous avons
travaillé avec différents partenaires du
territoire aussi bien des associations
que des laboratoires mais aussi le musée
de la ville dans cette exposition vous
allez donc découvrir à la fois les
concepts clés et scientifique de la
conquête spatiale de l'exploration
spatiale avec des manipulations
présentée
conçu par le cnes jusqu'au 18 décembre
la chapelle de la commanderie des
templiers se transforme en terrain
d'expérience à découvrir la maquette de
rosetta flottant dans les airs ou encore
ce téléviseur qui ressemblerait presque
un casque d'astronautes nous avons dans
les collections du musée des objets sur
le design et les modes de vie des années
60 et 70
ces objets évoque l'espace par leur
forme par leurs matériaux parce que ça
correspond premiers pas sur la lune et
donc les designers s'inspirer beaucoup
de ces formes
de l'espace pour
pour dessiner les leurs objets
comprendre la formation des planètes
l'apparition de la vie et l'évolution de
l'univers un moyen ludique d'avoir la
tête dans les étoiles
[Musique]